using social media to assassinate
someone that sounds crazy
you could do that sitting at home on
your couch in pajamas before there was
anything like an internet or social
media there was still disinformation
right
oh yes the first office of propaganda
was established by the catholic church
and you know what it still exists
why do people are they so surprised that
the russians are interfering in our
elections
the people who actually hold a patent on
something called the social credit
system
is actually facebook as a private
company you can pretty much do anything
you want but in this space
i'm afraid the battlefield is our own
territory not there
[Music]
welcome back to generally speaking today
we have rand waltzman
from rand i like that ran from ren and
we're going to talk about
influence we're going to talk about
disinformation
we're going to talk about a bunch of
things so rand i'd like to say thanks
for
joining the show and let's get right
into it so
tell the viewers a little bit about
yourself
well i guess the relevant part of this
is um
i was at uh at darpa i ran a program
called social media strategic
communications which is probably
well probably the largest social media
program ever funded by the government
was about 50 million dollars
and uh you know it ended in 2015
so judging by the way things are going i
guess i was a little bit ahead of my
time
um unfortunately you know i had to make
i made a statement at one meeting that
uh
the program benefited everybody in the
world except the united states
government who paid for it
that's really unfortunate since the us
government has
you know no part of the government has
really chosen to take advantage of these
techniques so but my interest in this
actually goes back a long way i mean the
original title
of my phd thesis well so i my ph is in
computer science
and i was an ai person by training and
um
the original title of my thesis in the
80 early 80s was
the automatic generation of plausible
disinformation
so so interesting original bot generator
uh yes well this was it was more like a
a tool an information tool you know i
had this whole concept of infra
disinformation management systems i
thought information managers you know
that's
that's limited interest but
disinformation management systems now
that's really the ticket
so this whole theory just you know as
opposed to information theory i had a
whole idea of disinformation theory work
done so
so yeah so i was uh i was out there
pretty early so yeah so my interest in
this goes back a long way
so so it sounds like you were one of
those kids that
really got into the lies oh yeah
oh yeah so um
so there's a um you or you've uh
told me before that you were advising on
some television shows
and yeah one of the things you talked
about was um
using social media to assassinate
someone that
that sounds crazy but uh can you can you
talk us through that
oh sure so it this was uh
it was a show called homeland and i was
giving some little advice on social
media there in fact i
i guess it was because of me that they
introduced the whole concept of social
media to the show at all
um but yeah so one of the meetings early
meetings i had with those guys i told
them i said we can do lots of
interesting things with social media
like assassinating people i said like
physically assassinating
and they said well you know they looked
at me and shocked i said well how could
that possibly work so i explained it
and i said it's a variation on the old
mission impossible
story so you remember mission impossible
the tv show
they would they would have they would
get an assignment to assassinate some
guy
and they would have to infiltrate his i
mean physically infiltrate his
organization
and then they convinced his um his
colleagues
that he had somehow ratted them out or
turned on them or done something to them
so that they would conveniently go and
then put a bullet in the guy's head
and then the mission impossible team
then they had to sneak away they had
vans waiting for them they were always
in custom so it was always a big
complicated thing
so i explained to these guys today you
can do that so much easier you could do
that sitting at home
on your couch in your pajamas no problem
at all and all you have to do
is take your target you do a profile of
your target
see what it is you know what it is
they're interested what what's their
platforms and positions
and then you go out in the space and you
locate a small group
of sort of real pathological nut cases
really violent who whose views are
diametrically opposed to this guy
they may never heard of him but that you
can fix that
so then the idea is you start spreading
rumors that are designed to get exactly
to those people
and they get so incensed you push them
over that you see you know that this guy
either said something or did something
which he made probably
never done or said doesn't matter but is
plausible as consistent with his beliefs
if they looked him up and know anything
about him
so then they get so angry that you push
that they go over and conveniently put a
bullet in the guy's head
or blow him up or whatever and you
didn't have to get off you didn't even
have to get out of pajamas to do the
whole thing
so it's great many many fantastic
possibilities so that's fiction
that was fiction yes and they actually
did that in the show
and and but there are actual uh elements
of disinformation
that predate social media right you're
and that's one of the things that you're
an expert on kind of the
the the evolution of disinformation so
you know before there was anything like
an internet or social media
there was still disinformation right oh
yes this is a long and dishonorable
tradition i can say
i mean it goes i mean in this i was
i think it was in the 17th century that
the first
office of propaganda it was actually
called the office of propaganda was
established
by the catholic church i think was pope
gregory
i don't remember the 15th or something
it was like a 1630
i think if i remember the dates right
around that time frame
and that it was called the office of
propaganda and you know what it still
exists
the office is still really yes a few
years ago they but they have their own
web pages if you go to the vatican's web
pages
i mean you can you can read the whole
history of the office of propaganda
you know and uh so that was really sort
of the first
official you know official on paper
start of the whole business
it's even then it was old news i mean
right so
but but the modern version of this
information
goes back certainly to the
at the beginning of the last century
so for example one of the greatest
pieces of disinformation
ever perpetrated in modern times was
something called the protocols of the
elders of zion
and it was all about jewish conspiracy
theories to take over the world and
everything else
and it was created by a guy named
rajkovsky
who was the head of the paris office
of the ochrana which was the tsarist
secret police this
is around 1900. so you know
this guy was great he did all kinds of
tricks like that i mean he was it was a
whole big thing with him
so you know the kgb they just inherited
the ohrana the tsarist playbooks
and then when the kgb fell apart the
modern russians just inherited the
kgb's playbooks so there's a long
tradition
of doing this kind of work there and in
fact in the soviet union
uh the kgb i mean they had always been
involved in this kind of work but they
actually formed the first
official office of that was called
department d
of the first chief directorate of the
kgb which was the cage first chief
director was the foreign section
department d was created in the early
fifties and the d stood for
disinformation which in russian is
disinformation of course
and that department was elevated to a
service
which is a higher level organization
service a
at the end of the 60s and so a stood for
oddly enough that the initials for
active measures are the same in russian
am
in russian it's so it's the same am
and it was elevated to a service so yeah
so these things go back long long way
so so today when you look at
what's going on both internationally
uh and i know you're you're really
focused on russia
have you started to look at the chinese
communist party at all
oh domestically like how do you how
how would you go about describing
the the interplay between active
measures coming from russia coming from
china
and then just the the political parties
here in the united states
using some of the same techniques i
would believe
uh against each other you know is how
does that how does it all work together
in your mind
well you know people have different
approach i mean i've i've always been
into the chinese for a long time i mean
that's i
haven't haven't focused on russia
because i because i think the chinese uh
you know
these are really serious players they do
a great job they're well organized
um they have a slightly different or
have had up to now i would say a slight
diff
quite a different philosophy than the
russians on how to do how to do this
kind of work they've been
they've been you know the early times
they were focused really more on their
own populations
i mean look after all if you were
sitting on top of one and a half you
know 1.4 billion people wouldn't you be
scared i mean
i i'd be worried i want to make sure i
had things under control
so i mean i i get that i understand that
um so yeah but but but their techniques
have gone back a long way one of the one
of the greatest
ideas i think that they've implemented
is this whole
idea of the social credit scoring system
now what's interesting about the social
credit scoring system
is that the people who actually hold a
patent on something called the social
credit system it's actually facebook
and facebook took the patent over from
friendster which was an old social media
company from earliest from the early
2000s
and in 2006 i think it was they filed a
patent on a social credit system
but it wasn't granted and then in 2011
or 12 something like that
facebook took over the patent and saw it
through to come to completion the patent
was granted in 2015. so facebook
actually thinks the patent on the social
credit system
but but the chinese are the people who
really implemented them i mean serious
big time
i mean they really you know they really
got it and the fantastic thing about it
is the idea of crowdsourcing crowd
control
i mean it's it's ingenious really isn't
i
they took the idea way beyond what the
friendster guy had in mind
so crowdsourcing country core you know
when you especially have a crowd that
size
it's actually a brilliant idea so so
that's only one thing they do they have
but
but the thing about the chinese is that
their
methods their approach is actually full
spectrum across
all of branches of government and they
attempt to coordinate it
i mean really coordinate all of their
activities across all types of influence
activities you know centrally so
while they try to central control they
also have some kind of distributed
implementation so sometimes some of the
elements work across purposes
against each other and sometimes they
trip themselves up but but generally
speaking
i mean they're doing they're doing a
fine job i like that
then you threw in the generally speaking
so that great
yes generously promoted my show in the
midst of the show that's great
no so and this is what i've contended
for a long time is that we
invented all these tools and to your
point about darpa we've spent a lot of
money trying to understand how to use
technology
to do disinformation of course facebook
amazon google are very good at using
technology to influence
people to buy more shoes for example but
then what the chinese communist party
did was take those tools
and then update them and and make them
useful for controlling the population i
like the
the the point that you made about
crowdsourcing crowd control because
that's exactly what they do
they have their 50 army that is that is
basically there to
um not stifle descent only stifle viral
descents
right so as soon as it hits a certain
level then they start to basically
squelch it so
and when you're looking at like if you
were going to
and you certainly worked on this at
darpa but
what what would what have you
recommended to the government
because i know this is a hard problem in
terms of democracies how do you
how do you prevent this kind of stuff
from undermining
our principles our values our society
our democracy our institutions
what have you recommended and has any of
those recommendations ever been adopted
or is it just something where you think
that
we haven't recognized the threat to
america these things
well so the first problem is that i mean
at this point
you know pointing the fingers to foreign
influence
it's almost almost a form of
misdirection
because i would say that by now the
domestic
domestically originated threat is
probably even bigger than the foreign
one
i mean think about it right how is it
you know
people heard you know talk a lot about
the hundred thousand dollars that the
russians might have spent on facebook
ads
you know the 2016 elections but you
hardly ever hear anybody talk about the
hundred million dollars
that the russians spent on american
public relations firms
hiring them to push their agenda
catching public relations a great
example
the story came out in 2015 that peop
that the russians had invested at least
50 million dollars on their books
i mean to uh you know to push their
agenda so so things like are you talking
like
cambridge analytica stuff like that is
that what you is that what you're
referring to
companies that do that basically um
use these databases or use these
platforms to
to you know they sell out the ability to
to um to both understand but also
influence
the the members sure they're mercenaries
i mean
these guys i mean but think about it
right how would you ever compare
a person's i you know some guy sitting
at the internet research agency
petersburg with a guy sitting in
washington dc
who works for ketchum or some other
other public relations
organization like that how you can't
compare those people
the guy in dc will beat the pants off
the russian guy any day
because he knows he knows the people he
knows that it knows the society
he knows yeah not only that but he
probably came from the hill
okay to start with so he's got all the
connections i mean for the at least
one that part of their business he's got
you know he's got all the connections
they can pick up a phone they can get a
reporter to hold the story they i mean
they can do all sorts of things you know
they
they know the people intimately who are
sure
it's in its intersection of the ability
to have these financial
transactions with the uh the expertise
that goes into
um you know using data for influence is
that is that what you're saying
sure the combination of the two yes
plus the fact plus the fact that you
know unlike the government
they don't they don't have any
restrictions you know they don't have to
worry about
human subject protection they don't have
to worry about privacy laws or anything
else
what right was that as a private company
you can pretty much do anything you want
pretty much in this space yep
getting back to you know so basically
sounds like the number one policy
recommendation that you would have is
stop
allowing for state actors
to pay companies like now you mentioned
ketchum like what are the top
companies that you would say in the
country that that utilize these types of
technologies and techniques
to influence on behalf of their clients
well i mean most most of the big all the
big pr companies
i mean you know it's all of them
basically though
they'll tell you these are i mean
they're mercenaries they're they're
hired guns
you pay them to promote an idea they
promote it i mean
i had a friend i give an example i have
a friend who worked at some company
one of these companies a smaller one
and he was asked um by another company
who had just gotten a new a big client
this is
this is in the u.s now this is not
overseas big client
and who was that he so this guy said
well okay well who's the client
well we can't tell you until you're
ready to sign on the dotted line
so they okay they negotiate and they go
okay fine
so now the guy's ready to sign up and
he's okay well tell me who the client is
so this client turns out
without naming any names to be a really
bad bad guy
in another country that in the
leadership of another country
so this friend of mine said yeah you
know what that's where i draw the line
i'm not doing that
but the company that was trying to hire
him had no issues with it whatsoever
right
no compunction about you know it's just
money right
yeah it's a it's a business that's one
of one of our biggest exports
has been this has been influence
peddling
as a business actually quite frightening
uh yes
and we're you know and we're really good
at it at least
as long as you're outside the government
the us government is worthless but the
the private sector is spectacular so
people would
take what you just said and they're like
how can the u.s government with
all its money and all its power be
useless in this in this area and
you and i both know it's because in a
lot of respects it's because of our laws
and our system and our democracy and our
respect for privacy and
uh individual um uh individual
prerogative
but can you kind of elaborate on you
know why the governments think so bad
when it comes to protecting americans
from influence well so you have to
realize right that you know it's not
only these
these you know foreign actors who are
employing these countries it's also u.s
politicians u.s politicians u.s
corporations basically
everybody's in the same kind of guys so
whose advantage is it to shut them down
i mean you know our elected officials
they're not going to gain anything
they're not going to do anything because
they all use the same people
so i mean that's kind of the that's kind
of the
where the mess that we're in right i
mean it it's not the it's not any
elected of politicians
to any elected politicians advantage to
actually do anything
about the problems i mean they can hide
behind privacy laws and they can hide
behind bad optics and they can hide
behind all kinds of things
but at the end of the day it's not to
their advantage to actually
do anything proactive about the problem
so but the other thing is even even so
you know go back to comparing with the
chinese
one of the things about the chinese is
that the chinese have an actual message
that they're trying to put out
you know their messaging is clear it's
clear and it's consistent
across the government so and they have
to they've built up this enormous
machinery to put the message out
now from our side what's the message
there is so far there is no message
actually so even if we had the machinery
what are you gonna say you know it's
like somebody introduced me to somebody
one time
and hey look this guy speaks eight
languages and the other guy said okay
but does he have anything to say
so even if we had the machinery we have
nothing to say really
we used to have the us information
agency that was disbanded in 1999 which
was focused on public diplomacy
and did that for the us government
during the cold war
but we we got rid of it and and now
if you look at the agency for global
media
voice of america radio free asia ready
for europe
they're um their conflicted because on
the one hand they say well we have to
adhere to journalistic standards
um and on the other hand we have to
promote u.s principles and values
and so the first one says that while
we're promoting u.s principles and
values
we also have to give tehran beijing
pyongyang
and moscow equal airtime because that's
journalistic not prerogative but you
know what i'm saying
that's that's journalistic standards
you're upholding journalistic standards
if you have a balanced view
but what we're talking about here is a
is a view of the us government versus a
totalitarian regime
and that we should give the totalitarian
regime equal air time
to to our own government this is this is
the lunacy
upon which our government you know rests
its its
you know voice right well
it the the problem is it does doesn't
have a voice
right i mean that's at the end of the
day that's the real problem
as is drowned out by all of these
countries that do have a voice and
and really when you get right down to
the our national security strategy it's
a recognition that
number one we don't have a voice number
two we're not
we're not approaching these challenges
and ways that the chinese communist
party and the russians are
which are primarily to use um
relationships and disinformation to
create
geopolitical advantage and and we on the
other hand are running around having
these wars all over the place spending
trillions of dollars
and as you know and i know they're
spending very little money
but getting a lot more a lot more umph
at the united nation
at the wto at the world bank at the imf
at the world health organization so so
again i ask you
you know what recommendations have you
made and then what have you know
because i've known you a while now and
uh you've had
you've always had great um understanding
of the problem
and great recommendations but i'm
i'm concerned because that's never
translated into
more of a recognition within you know
our own foreign policy
making process that we need to do
something about it what so what
when you talk to people about this is it
just
do they give you platitudes or how do
you you know how do they respond to you
generally well generally i mean like
when i was a darp i was
going around in a government talking to
all sorts of people and basically
you know they just didn't want to hear
it well that's you know
we can't do anything about it i mean
people hide behind authorities
issues they hide behind privacy laws
they hide behind all kinds of things any
excuse not to
do do anything about the problem and so
you know what why did they disband the
u.s information agency
you know i i was in a meeting so you
know there used to be something called
the active measures working group
okay which was disbanded just around the
time of just right after the dissolution
of the soviet union
and the purpose of the active measures
working group was to actually counter
soviet active measures
and um you know i mean right
which never stopped i i mean no in fact
why do people are they so surprised uh
that the russians are interfering
interfering in our elections yes
i it's it's unreal okay so how is it i
was at a um
so a guy in english got peter pomerance
if they wrote an
a a report him a couple other guys about
russian
news influence operations so this was
this is a few years back
and i was at the coming out party for
this report and
a friend of mine who was one of the last
members of the active measures working
group as a matter of fact and the the
guy who wrote the final report
um the great todd leventhal one of the
great unsung heroes of the state
department and if you want a spectacular
guest on your show you should get him
um yes yes i'll be happy to send you his
contact information
but you know he and i were talking to a
woman
a very senior official in the state
department and i asked her i said
whatever possessed you to just
you know to disband the academic working
group
and her she looked me right in the eye
with todd standing there right next to
me
and she said well the cold war was over
it wasn't necessary anymore
wow spectacular answer i said
so my response to that was i said well
was was that a view that was widely held
among the senior leadership in the state
department she says oh yes i said you
know what that explains plenty
that explains everything yeah i i don't
know
i didn't even how could i respond to
that i just i know okay
so here's here's the deal i'm going to
make you secretary of defense
and i'm going to give you i'm going to
give you just
for to to help you a bit i'm going to
give you a few nuclear weapons you know
so you'll have those
um then you tell me how much money i
need to give you
so that you can play a little bit
because right now i'm giving you 800
billion dollars what if i
what if i'm trump and i say okay i've
i've
been giving you 800 billion dollars and
we spending this money and
and i'm not getting anything out of it
the everybody's going with the chinese
and they won't listen to us
you know if i gave you rent if i gave
you some money you know how much of that
800 billion dollars could i get back and
then you could just
you could just help me begin to shape
the world in ways
using all these tools because
globalization's not going away the
internet's going not going away
you know ai you you're an ai expert
okay how would you take how much money
would it cost me and what would
you know how would that look well so the
thing of it is
it isn't really so much about the money
because it isn't doesn't take that much
money
and and that is evidenced by the fact
that they're going to build roads and
bridges
yes but right sure you could do that but
i mean but but
yes i mean with the basic information
part of it it is not that expensive and
that's why
all these guys are doing this for a song
basically
so it doesn't take what it really takes
it takes a complete change in mentality
and that's a lot harder i mean it's
easier for somebody to throw money at
the problem it's a lot harder for
somebody to actually change the attitude
and that's where the biggest problem
lies at the moment
so even as secretary of defense it isn't
sufficient because i mean okay you can
deal with one small piece of the problem
but you can't deal comprehensively with
the problem
i mean what the chinese have understood
is that it has to be a whole of
government type of approach
so the entire government has to be
involved it cannot be one branch of any
government the government by itself
that that doesn't work so if you're
going to actually message effectiveness
no messaging is you know like
it's this is a sort of a hierarchy ever
right so at the very top you have to
we're going to what's your key message
so the chinese
part of their key message is look we're
the good guys we're here to help if you
just listen to us and you let us help
you
we're going to help you out you know
that that's it right where everybody
should play nice
it's a win-win for everybody i mean
that's essentially what their top level
message is
and then they do everything they can you
know spreading all down the
the hierarchy to get that message out
so the first thing you actually really
need to do is to create an organization
which can which actually can represent
the government
as a whole i mean accurately and that
everybody will cooperate with you know
with some direction can be set
and then take and then implemented down
down the tree
so that's that's really the biggest
thing that needs to be done and
it you know the whole authorities issue
needs to be fixed
it's all i mean there's only right now
there is one person in the entire united
states government
that doesn't need a presidential finding
to put out any rubbish that comes into
his head out onto social media
only one person well guess what the
president
doesn't need a presidential finding
he can do what he wants say what he
wants and there's nobody to do anything
about it
but if you're anybody else in the
government and you try to do the similar
kind of thing boy to come down on you
like a ton of bricks
so so what i had so my recommendation
then is to basically put you in the
white house
next to the president help him design
his information campaign
and just let him use that platform
well it has see but to think of it it
has to be something
beyond any individual office or any
individual
it has to be some government approach
yes and it has to also be
has to have you know staying power it
has to
regardless of outcomes of elections it
has to be able to continue ongoing it
has to have continuity
who who do you think today you know uh
in
in government you know at a high level
understands
the things that you're talking about you
know who would you say that
really gets this idea that you know
using information um and particularly
disinformation from our adversaries and
understanding that and protecting the
country and then
using it on behalf of the national
interests who do you think
gets that because i don't find a lot of
people in national security policy
making circles
that even understand what you're talking
about no i i don't know there isn't any
i mean
you know when i used to when i was at
darwin i had to give briefings on the
hill which i had to do now and then
i mean i always walked away in tears
because
the lack of understanding was like
phenomenal
i just i was so sad and so really
horrifying
i mean these guys did they're completely
clueless i don't know
elbridge colby who wrote the current um
defense strategy national defense
strategy just came out with an
article in foreign affairs that said
that the chinese communist party's
approach is not ideological
and in fact if we consider it to be
ideological that we're actually creating
danger for ourselves
and i looked at that i'm like you don't
understand the chinese communist party
their entire campaign is based on
control of the narrative and controlling
of the way that
they are viewed and if that's not
ideological i don't know i'm not sure
what is
what well i well i think when they i
think you know when when people like
that use the word ideology they're
talking about some like
a philosophy some kind of overall
philosophy but you know just saying
we're in control we're in control where
we you know we
we're gonna we're gonna manage things
the way we think they should be managed
and i don't know if i would call that an
ideology i mean that's just good
business
i mean yeah that's just business when
you make those kinds of claims
you know that your understanding of the
problem in my mind is diminished because
you don't realize that the
you know we believe in the west that war
is politics by other means
yeah chinese believe that politics is
war by other means
absolutely political yes so why would
this combat when you can convince your
adversary
that their own system is flawed i mean
this is
to me this is a this is art of warfare
well so you know i don't know that
you're gonna convince them that their
system is flawed
but you know it this is part of the
issue with the with the defense
department
so you know traditionally a battlefield
is where the fighting happens
and the battlefields are you know
preferably on foreign territory
but in this space i'm afraid that the
battlefield is our own territory not
theirs
right here right i mean you know what
they do with their population is their
problem
what what they're doing with our
population or what we're doing with our
own population
that's that's our problem right and so
right right so the problem is that the
real battlefield where this
the battle is raging is right here in
our own backyard
to say to the defense department for
example that well you know you can only
do operations on foreign soil
or you know and foreign well so you know
i don't understand that if if an actual
physical army invaded the united states
are you going to say well you know we
can only act on the foreign
soil so you know sorry we can't help you
yeah
do what you want right you know it's not
our problem
we're only authorized to work on foreign
territory is that
is that helpful you know would that
actually happen i hope not but
yeah you and i see things uh very much
the same way and i really have enjoyed
having you on
um generally speaking uh i always enjoy
talking to you because i feel like i
i have found a kindred spirit in
understanding
warfare in the way that i should have
understood it
from the very beginning but i was always
taught you know that
putting a bomb on somebody's head uh is
far more effective than getting them to
you know do something to them to their
own self so
it's been it's been a tremendous um
honor of mine to get to know you
and and learn from you so i really thank
you for coming on general
generally speaking and and we're going
to have you on again because
there's so much more to cover in this
and and you really understand it
well i thank you so much for having me
it was great and uh i look forward to
coming back again and i wish you a great
success with the podcast
thank you ryan
[Music]